- Hey, out there.
Welcome in, welcome, welcome, welcome
to another edition of 'Market Takes.'
Today, we are breaking down
the latest US retail sales report.
It seems like the start of,
what I've decided to call,
Soft Landing Summer.
We got Soft Landing
Summer going on right now.
We're gonna take a look,
I'm gonna explain to you what that means,
I'm just gonna leave it out there,
but a retail sales report that
I think has got a lot of folks
out there in the markets excited,
we're gonna break all that down.
We're gonna talk about what
this US retail sales report showed,
how that compared to expectations.
We're gonna of course talk about
the market reaction,
we're gonna take you through
how markets reacted to this report.
We're gonna talk about earnings
and how this earnings season,
what we've seen so far,
has kind of really locked in the report
and what the report showed,
and really backed that
in terms of what investors are thinking
about the market and the economy.
And then we're gonna talk
about the Fed meeting because,
of course, we know that
everything is based on the Fed,
and that's why when we talk
about Soft Landing Summer,
that's really what it's all about.
It's all about these expectations
for the Federal Reserve
and what they're gonna do
at their meeting next week.
Of course, we'll be here on Market Takes.
We hope you'll be with us as well.
Last thing, we're gonna talk
about what comes next,
'cause we are always looking forward,
even though it is backward-looking data.
So first things first,
let's talk about today's report
and the numbers that we saw.
I wanna throw up here on your screen
a chart of what we've got
from the retail sales report.
Now, what you see there is
on the right of your screen,
you see three straight positive reports.
Today's report was 0.2%
increase month over month,
so June sales rising 0.2% from May.
May was actually revised higher.
So you had a 0.5% increase in May,
and so you see those numbers over there
on the right looking pretty healthy
after we had seen four of
the last seven reports
coming in being negative.
And you see those two
bars there going lower,
and then you see that
big increase in January.
Before that, we had two negative reports,
so there was some worry
that we were gonna continue on
this downward trajectory,
that we had reached this place
where we were just moving lower,
that retail sales were gonna be negative.
That was definitely a
bad thing for retail,
it was a bad thing for the economy.
But what we have seen
the past three months is
a reversal of that trend.
Now, wanna direct your attention
to a different chart,
wanna put the year over year change
up here on your screen,
in terms of what we're
seeing on retail sales,
and what you see there is
a bit of a different picture.
You see that retail sales number
just going consistently down.
And when we talk about
Soft Landing Summer,
this is what we're talking about.
Now, this is comparing to
a year before.
You see those numbers there
on the left side of your screen?
Those are going high above 10%, above 15%.
Then you see us come down.
And the big thing about retail sales is
retail sales don't take inflation
out of the picture.
So as we're seeing inflation come down,
we have seen those retail
sales numbers come down,
and that's what the Federal
Reserve wants to see.
When we talk about a soft landing,
well this is what they wanna see.
They don't wanna see
those numbers going negative, turning bad,
and then the economy goes lower
and folks go out of business,
they start laying people off.
No, no, no.
What the Federal Reserve wants to see is
exactly what you're seeing
up there on your screen,
which is those numbers start to come down,
retail sales start to reduce lower,
you start to see a deceleration
into maybe a slowdown,
and then the economy can
start to pick back up
as we move back towards
two percent inflation.
So you don't really wanna see zero,
you don't really only wanna see negative.
What you wanna see is the number
for June is 1.5%,
so you've got a 1.5% increase.
Again, it's from that number
on the far left side of your screen.
So what we have seen is a small increase
from a very high number,
and those base effects are gonna start
to play a real big role
as we move forward
and as we continue.
Because you see,
as you see there on your screen,
the numbers are lower
so we'll have a lower number to compare to
when we get into September, October,
those fall numbers,
because inflation was declining,
retail sales were declining.
But from what we're seeing right now,
we are seeing just the sales slow down,
not stop, not crash,
not move to a strongly negative print,
but just slow down
to a slower increase,
a slower pace of increase.
So retail sales still picking up
on a year-over-year basis.
But again, this just illustrating
that we are seeing this slowdown,
and again what I'm terming
Soft Landing Summer.
If you hear that anywhere else,
they stole it from me.
We came up with a right
here on Market Takes first.
Don't forget, don't sleep on us here
at Market Takes.
Listen, when we're looking at
where consumers are spending, right?
Because we've gotta dig into
these numbers a little bit
to find out,
"Okay, what is this really saying to us?"
Even those numbers are pretty positive
in terms of what it means
for the Federal Reserve.
So we saw spending online continuing,
really leading all categories
for the monthly gain of
1.9% month-over-month,
and up 9.4%, almost 10%, year-over-year.
So those online sales,
what they call 'non-store
retailers,' staying strong.
Bars and restaurants,
the service industry,
well that is still positive,
up 0.1% month-over-month,
but up 8.4% year-over-year,
so looking very similar to
the overall chart.
We are seeing services inflation,
as in what you're paying for services,
like when you go out to a bar
and get a drink,
when you go out to a restaurant
and people serve you,
when you go get your haircut
at the barbershop,
or go to the auto mechanic.
We're seeing that really
holding up inflation,
but what you don't want is for it
to be pushing inflation too high,
which is what we were seeing last year
and earlier in this year,
which is the inflation rate
and the sales rate.
Because we know when people
are going out, spending money,
they're buying, buying, buying,
well, we know prices are going up
and if people are paying
those high prices,
the prices just continue to escalate,
and that's not what the Fed wants to see,
that's not what you and I wanna see.
Those higher prices?
we don't want that.
We want inflation to come down
and really get those price increases
more in control,
see that deceleration.
One big surprise, I think,
in terms of the positive side,
was the big increase in furniture
and home furnishing sales;
Up 1.4% month-over-month
but down 4.6% year-over-year.
So furniture and those
things, home furnishings,
had been declining pretty consistently,
and then this month,
you saw a surprise pickup,
1.4% month-over-month increase.
We'll see if that's just a one month blip,
maybe things got off on a weird track,
maybe Big Mike's Furniture
Warehouse had a big sale
and that just pushed the data up.
But what we are seeing is
a notable month-over-month increase
that's also down 3.2% over
the last six months.
So going against the trend is
basically what I'm saying
for furniture and home furnishings.
The biggest decreases,
gasoline stations, that
has been consistent,
and that's a lot of why you're seeing
those consumer sentiment
numbers really take off.
We saw the latest University
of Michigan Consumer Sentiment Index push
way above expectations,
and a big part of that has been
the decline that we
have seen in gas prices.
Well, we know when gas prices go down,
gas stations don't make as much money,
and that was down 1.4% month-over-month,
22.7% year-over-year.
So gas station revenue really just,
boo, diving lower.
and again, that's not good
if you're a gas station owner,
but that's great for the average person
who's gotta fill up the truck
to get to work,
or fill up the car to get to work,
and they're spending less
on gas stations than they were,
about 23% less than they were,
a year ago.
Sporting goods, hobby, musical instrument,
and some books,
those down one percent month-over-month,
about 1.3% year-over-year.
Building materials, garden
supplies, also down.
The big picture here is
goods versus services.
We know that goods are falling
because we're just not spending as much,
going out and buying things
like tables, air conditioners,
stuff like that for our house,
and we're spending more on services,
going out having a good time.
But what the Federal Reserve
does not want to see is
too many people going out
and pushing those services prices way up.
That's not what we're seeing
in this report.
Overall, you're not seeing
a major acceleration
in services data,
that would contrast
or offset the decline
we're seeing in good prices.
So good prices, declining;
Services, holding up.
And that's holding those
retail sales numbers
above flat, above zero,
at 1.5% year-over-year,
0.2% month-over-month,
like we saw this month.
So that's the big picture takeaway
when it comes to this report.
Now, let's take a look at
what we're seeing from the markets,
and I wanna direct your attention
to the big picture overview.
We're seeing some
interesting things happen
in the stock market, I think.
Much more a reaction
to the earnings reports that we've seen.
But want to throw up here,
on your screen,
the market reaction that we are seeing.
And so, this is the big picture overview.
What you're seeing there is the NASDAQ,
that's negative overall on the day,
but the Dow is up about 0.34%,
and the S&P 500 about flat.
So what we're seeing is a mixed reaction.
Like I said, I think
the NASDAQ is reacting
to some of those bank earnings.
We saw actually a number of
smaller banks are in the NASDAQ,
and the earnings reports we saw
this morning are a bit of a mixed picture,
but those bigger banks
and some of those big picture things
that it says about the economy, as in...
And I'll talk to you a
little bit about that later,
we won't get too much into that now.
But I think that's why you're seeing
the reaction from the stock market.
When we look at bonds,
another interesting thing I saw,
and I wanna direct your attention here
to the 30 year bond yield
and what you're seeing there, right?
A pretty limited reaction.
The data came out around eight o'clock,
so that's right around this area
when we're talking about reaction.
So pretty minimal, right?
10 year, you see about the same thing.
As we get lower in yield,
you start to see a bigger
reaction from that data,
but then that filtered out.
So five year you're seeing
an even bigger reaction.
Right down here, boom,
you see this takeoff.
Around the three year,
even bigger reaction.
And the two year, which
is most closely tallied,
or most closely aligned,
with expectations for what
the Federal Reserve will do,
you did see a big reaction
but that has kind of petered out
of the data.
Let's talk really
quickly about currencies.
Not much reaction here from the data,
but did see an interesting reaction,
I thought, from Bitcoin.
When we look up here at Bitcoin,
a big turndown after that data.
We don't know if that's
necessarily related,
it could be, it may not be.
Bitcoin obviously much more traded
by big time Wall Street investors
these days than it was,
but still often its own story.
And as you see right there,
a big pickup in crude oil
that we've seen recently.
This wasn't really in
response to the data,
but a pretty solid increase.
But you're seeing across the board...
Except for copper,
one place you might wanna look at,
"okay if there's
something to worry about,"
those copper prices lower,
but not a big reaction from the data.
And this really just kind of illustrating
the reaction, or maybe lack
of a big reaction to this data,
because a lot of this
was priced in, right?
The reason that we're calling it
Soft Landing Summer,
and not Soft Landing June
or Soft Landing Retail Sales report,
'cause the data has pretty
consistently backed this theme,
that things are starting to slow down,
inflation's slowing down,
job gains slowing down,
retail sales slowing down.
Not falling off a cliff, not halting,
not backing up and turning negative,
but just slowing down,
doing exactly what Fed
Chair Jerome Powell said
he wants to see from this data.
That's exactly what we're getting.
Let's talk really quickly about
the earnings reports that we saw,
that we've gotten today
and then going back to last week,
because they have really backed
the story of, again,
this Soft Landing Summer,
and perhaps a pickup and acceleration
that gets the economy
kicked back into gear.
That could be good, that could be bad,
but we'll talk about it
and cross that bridge when we come to it.
Bank earnings so far have shown increases
in loan defaults,
but still we are historically low.
So we're seeing loan
loss provisions increase
just a little bit.
That's banks saying,
"Hey, we're a little worried
"about what's going on,
'we're gonna put a little
more money to the side
"just in case people aren't able
"to pay back their loans."
But they're not doing that at a big scale,
they're not doing it in a big way.
So we are seeing just a
little bit of caution.
Customers at JP Morgan,
Wells Fargo, Citigroup,
spent more on credit cards,
more borrowers carrying
over those balances.
I've been telling you all for months
to watch those credit balances,
but those numbers in
terms of the comparison
to the previous month have been declining.
We are seeing lower use,
in terms of month-over-month.
Still, year-over-year,
you're seeing a pretty big pickup
in terms of credit,
folks still borrowing
money to pay for things.
That could be worrisome in the long run
because we have seen the price of credit,
or those interest rates on credit cards,
continue to rise,
and we are still at
historically high levels.
But right now we're not seeing defaults,
we're not seeing folks not
paying back their debt.
And the banks really reconfirmed that
and reiterated that for us.
Citigroup CEO Jane Fraser said,
"Overall, I'd say we are seeing
"a more cautious consumer,
"but not necessarily a recessionary one."
Again, we're talking about it,
Soft Landing Summer.
Morgan Stanley reported earnings
just this morning, really kind of...
Their CEO, James Gorman,
reiterating the same thing.
Their second quarter profit fell 13%,
but they were hurt by a...
They were hurt a lot by the decline
in trading revenue,
not necessarily anything
in terms of their consumers.
CEO James Gorman saying, quote...
Saying, sorry, this isn't a quote,
but a summation of what he said.
"Client activity was subdued
"to start the quarter
"but ended on a stronger note."
We were seeing that
really across the board.
We heard that from
JPMorgan in their earnings.
Citigroup CEO Jane Fraser.
Really, a pickup overall at the end.
Folks are starting to turn a corner
in terms of their
confidence in the economy
and we are seeing that overall.
Bank earnings show Americans bank balances
and how they're spending their money,
and we have learned the consumer
really is in okay shape right now.
Not anything to be worried about.
Slowing down, more cautious.
Those are good things, right?
That's what the Fed wants to see.
The other interesting thing though,
as we talk about and we move to
what's going on with the Fed,
investors still very much expecting
the Federal Reserve to raise rates
at its meeting this month.
That's gonna be next week.
And we'll talk about that
here in just a second.
But this really telling us
that things are slowing down,
they're not screeching to a halt,
and that there's not really anything
that you should be worried about.
This is exactly what the
Federal Reserve wants.
Again, that's what the
data tells us so far.
So right now, where we are
seems like a good place.
Let's talk about the
Fed meeting right now.
Right now, when we look at
the Fed Funds futures market,
investors have placed a 97% likelihood
that the Federal Reserve will raise rates
at its next meeting.
So I wanna put up here
a chart on your screen
to just give you an idea
of where we are, right?
You see those Fed rates,
this is the Fed funds rate,
where we are over there
on the right of your screen.
This is as high as we've been really
at any time in the past 20 years.
This chart going all the way back to 2000.
And you see there,
we are approaching those levels,
those highs of 2008.
Those rates were kept there
for not very long,
and then the Fed had to start cutting
as we were going into that recession.
But historically, we are
at a very high level,
in terms of where the Fed has rates.
And the Fed is again expected to hike,
a 97% likelihood among investors
that they will raise rates again
in a week on July 26th.
We hope you'll be right
here on Market Takes
when we break down that decision,
break down the press conference
and all that.
But just wanna put this chart
up here on your screen
to illustrate where we are,
and where we've come from.
And we have now gotten very high up
on the Fed Funds rate,
and that's just kind of where we are.
So when we look out at
this upcoming Fed meeting,
I think this report,
along with some of the other data,
is gonna potentially give folks
a reason to say, "Hey, whoa, whoa, whoa.
"Why are you guys trying
"to raise rates again?
"We got Soft Landing
Summer happening already.
"Why are you guys raising rates?"
But that's what the Fed has locked in,
they've really locked in the market.
And it would be a very big surprise
if they did not raise rates
by 25 basis points
at their next meeting,
coming up next Wednesday.
So you're gonna wanna watch out for that.
I think this definitely locks in rates.
Investors were expecting
just one increase this year,
and that's gonna be in July.
And then, really, the market is predicting
the Fed will not raise rates again
for the rest of the year,
going all the way up to December.
This certainly locks that in,
and really I think cemented
those expectations.
And also though, the question becomes,
"Is the Fed now doing too much?"
Those folks who have already
said, "You know what?
"The Fed shouldn't have
raised rates this high,
"they shouldn't have done it,"
they are gonna be louder now,
as you hear from them,
"Oh, well look at retail sales,"
that report's already coming in,
it's already coming down.
"We already got Soft Landing Summer.
"What are you guys doing?"
That's gonna be an interesting debate
and we will see how that plays out.
What comes next?
Well, the earnings reports
keep coming this week.
We got Tesla, and Netflix,
United, Johnson & Johnson,
a whole host of others.
You're gonna wanna watch those
because I think those gonna tell us
a lot about the economy.
The Fed meeting next week
will be highly watched,
not for what the Fed does
but for what the Fed says.
We will be here 4:00 PM Eastern,
doing Market Takes on Wednesday.
I hope you'll be with us
there for Market Takes.
The second quarter GDP report comes out,
that will be tightly watched
because of how much GDP for
the first quarter was
raised over expectations,
and we could be seeing a repeat of that
in the second quarter number.
And of course, we'll be talking
about all that on Monday,
doing our look ahead for Market Takes.
So listen, I am Dion Rabouin,
reporter for the Wall Street Journal.
Appreciate you guys being with us,
and we hope that you'll do it with us
and be with us again next time.